the world's largest Organization for
police says it's fighting a mental
health crisis with an increasing number
of suicides by officers nationwide 188
have died by suicide so far this year
now that is twice the number of officers
who have died in the line of duty think
about that for a second yesterday police
chiefs from all around the country
gathered in Chicago to address the
crisis in a special forum for the very
first time Jephthah gaze has covered law
enforcement extensively and moderated
the discussion Jeff what did we learn
well good morning police commissioners
from around the country say removing the
stigma of seeking help is the first step
in combating this epidemic we met with
those inside affected by suicide and
those outside of the department on the
front lines of this fight he was
diagnosed with post-traumatic stress
which he suffered with 13 years at this
year's International Association of
Chiefs of Police conference in Chicago
finding solutions for a disturbing trend
in officer suicides was top of mind
Janis McCarthy understands the
importance of speaking up her husband
Paul a 21 year veteran of the
Massachusetts State Police took his own
life in 2006 what needs to change the
culture needs to change its that culture
what she calls a fear by police officers
against expressing their emotional and
mental health that may be contributing
to the increased police suicide rate she
believes her husband's suicide was
brought on by his mental and physical
struggles after he was run over by a bus
while on the job you'll be fine
suck it up it'll go away it didn't go
away
and the department didn't know what to
do with that earlier this year President
Trump authorized 7.5 million dollars
annually for the next five years for
national police suicide prevention
efforts including mental health
screening and more training let's just
saw admit what broken and join arms and
and let's talk about this stuff because
we're not meant to do this by ourselves
we're not meant to suppress all this
detective Matt Thornton has been with
the Zion Police Department in Illinois
for 16 years it's very very difficult
thornton admits to bottoming out from
the demands of the job and planning to
take his own life crying and going over
his plan and I see a lady walking in a
parking lot and she's coming straight to
my squad cars she knocks on my window
and she hands me this red cross and she
said you need this
it was the most real moment of my life
he says that moment changed his life and
made him realize that he needed to reach
out for help
something cops don't often do it needs
to come to the forefront because I'm
sick of it I'm I'm sick of crying
because I can see the signs because I
lived on Orton says that he is made at a
point in his life to help fellow
officers in need some departments do
have trained mental health professionals
on staff for support but there doesn't
appear to be a national standard for
treatment or even the data to know
what's really needed or available this
is such a tough situation it seems
because you expect police officers to be
so strong and confident and I've heard
officers say you know you go to seek
help and then they're judged and then
sometimes they ridicule which also makes
it hard for them I'm glad this is a
conversation job yeah that is the the
stigma right you have this profession
where you have to be macho and tough and
once you reveal this vulnerability are
you still gonna have a job and that's
been a lot of time talking about that
yes but these guys see so much and
experience so much out there in the
field well how can how could that not
affect you yes right your and that's
what they were saying if you're not
human well yeah of course you're not
gonna be effective but if you're human
and you see the kinds of things that
they see over and over and over again it
adds up
these officers always see people at the
worst day and the worst time of their
lives and they are humans they are human
thank you very much Jeff sure the
National Suicide Prevention lifeline is
open 24 hours a day for anybody who
needs help that number is there on your
screen
1-800 273 8255